we have about 2,000 backers is that
right we have 2300 reduces do we make a
difference between producers and
investors that produces are these people
buying in the store from three dollars
investors these people that is buying a
share of the movie from a thousand
dollars and we have 17 messes and two
thousand and three hundred produces the
average band of produces is almost
seventeen dollars is a lot it's almost
double of movie taken it is great and
there's also a lot of people supporting
the project organizations space agencies
actual cosmonauts people from the
industry peter broderick and how to the
pixel team and a lot of people and there
is also a very big community following
us I mean not producers maybe they
didn't wave to be producers but they are
following us following us and social
networks and they are all waiting for
the movie to to be related to watch it
there is a lot of attention are most of
the investors from Spain or where
geographically yeah investors are mostly
from Spain as for producers most of them
are from Spain because this is where we
reveal the community we are now writing
to the rest of the world we have a lot
to have people from eight countries I
think people from the states also there
are a lot of people here in the industry
try wanting to help
spreading the work also yeah we are
trying to get it more international this
is an international project will be
should in English everything we make is
in Spanish but also an English at the
same time so we are getting bigger it
sounds like though you've been at this
is it a year or two years or you're not
you know okay and at any point do you
feel worked out or maybe tired of the
project and if so how do you combat that
yeah us with any project a lot of times
but we decided instead of spending two
years with a screenplay under or iron
like knocking doors and receiving knows
we decided to involve the community and
to talk to them and tell them what we
were doing and asked them for help and
it's been amazing I mean it's exhausting
of course and it demands you a lot of
attention but you are talking to your
future audience and they are telling you
what they like what they don't like and
you are sharing with them all your
concerns and I mean every day we receive
an email from someone all over the world
telling us that we are amazing that they
love the project that it has been
inspirational so that helps a lot to
move forward to working on the project
and they also help us when we needed
moving something with an ask them for
example we the movies inspired a very
nice boy to book very small and we sold
out the first edition and we put a post
or blog saying okay anyone wants to a
sponsor a second edition of the book and
within 10 minutes three guys said okay
I'm going to play like thousand five
hundred bucks to make it possible and we
made it we made it
second edition and we're selling it now
and things like that I mean they are
they are really great you can get in
touch with the community and they also
help you with the creative process and
it's exhausting but also very rewarding
it's really nice on the days that you
don't make me feel as inspired as you
could what do you do to rev up the
engine because I know it's just a
constant fight you've got to keep going
so what do you do personally to kind of
keep the fire ignited a little bit I
tried to sleep and wake up and explain
later I don't know I'm and just try to
look back what to what we have done in
the last year what has been amazing and
all the conferences with made of
universities to explain the model and
all the talks we have with these people
telling us that they love the project
and that really helps to be there too
125 and then what are you doing an FM
and what's your experience been like
what we've been here invited by spanish
company to attend an immersion program
organized by the lady see to it gave a
lot of latin american and spanish
filmmakers and producers to know the
american market with have met a lot of
executives and people from the industry
from motion picture association from
Warner Brothers agent from CAA a lot of
really a lot of people to know how
everything works here and we are also
attending afm to try to spread the word
about the movie maybe find some
investors money from here and some
distributors that's the idea and I
realize this is looking into the future
but are you hoping for a distributor or
just want to sell it yourself from your
website well no absolutely we are
looking for distributors I mean they
will have to know the model we are
proposing it's kind of tricky because we
are going to distribute the movie for
free on the internet and at the same
time on DVD theaters televisions and the
internet so it's kind of difficult for
them to figure out because it's a very
new model but if anyone is interested we
are really willing to to look for
co-producers all around the world to try
to spread this model and see if it works
and lastly what has been the biggest
hurdle of this entire process and how
are you / coming in
well it's been difficult because we are
the first ones doing this I mean we
develop all this crap funding Creative
Commons distribution model or any it
works I mean if you waited it completely
works it's brown I mean everything is
engaged with the next part by this
difficulty it's very new when you're
first in something is difficult to move
forward it's been amazing and has had an
amazing success in Spain in Europe we're
beginning to get down here and that's a
good and bad I mean to be first is
amazing but very difficult sure they're
so still I mean you need to to really
fight a very traditional model
Oh